which way he's going to serve and he
tends to be very effective at all we're
going to see an owens defense
yeah so that is very rare with black you
can tell rajabov doesn't
believe in his chances in an open game
in a sicilian in a kingsport opening
he as black now he's about to set up
with the hippopotamus defense wow this
looks great frankly
already thinking it's only move five he
does castle the white king
rajabov bringing his knight to the
center out and i also have to bear in
mind that
didn't magnus play something very
similar with the black
pieces magnus has played everything in
his lifetime
um he loves to experiment with new
openings and there we see rajabov
bringing his night out
so it's not a pure hippopotamus defense
where black would actually put his
knight
next to the other knight especially
between these two guys all the pieces on
the board
for a long time it's gonna disturb him
that much magnus loves this type of
dress but i
completely disagree i think that
anything else rajabov would have tried
if he played any opening he's played in
the past i think
magnus would easily have neutralized
that uh calling fianchettos
both bishops on the longest possible
diagonals i think that would have been
maybe one way to unsettle magnus and
it's going to be quite effective
yeah black castling i expect to see
magnus very quickly bring his knight out
to that square the two white knights
keeping the white king nice and safe
perfect formation really cleverly saying
to raj above
how are you going to play with your lack
of space yeah and actually i
just trawling through my memory banks i
do remember
just randomly tuning in to chess24
twitch
and chess 24 they put on these great
banter blitz sessions i remember
rajabov playing a banter blitz game
against a very strong player and he used
this setup
as black so not the full hedgehog but
this exact setup is black pushing the
central pawn
magnus has two hours to try and beat him
but in a rapid game
i think it's a great practical try okay
at least from experience i think
uh even top ground masters they don't
like this type of tension when they only
need a draw continues in the center
he's like i'm not going to push a pawn
forward i'm going to keep on
asking you that's the dashboard bishop
to come out to you
yeah and there we have it and that's a
nice move
openings they often transpose to each
other you can play lots of different
moves you can play them in different
orders though
it's like a passive square but okay
black has developed his bishop now and i
would expect to see magnus carson jump
forward with his own bishop if not now
then over the next few turns
spending a bit of time i expect okay he
pushes a pawn
first so slightly strange to move the
queen across and then not fulfill that
idea by bringing the bishop out to that
right side but maybe he's saving that up
for later i really like that bishop
and it's just designed to soften up the
dark squares around the black king i
mean because it does look
at first sight a little bit
anti-positional you know you're like
well what's the black bishop doing there
you know it's just passive it's stuck
behind a pawn but it's such an important
piece with
so much potential that uh once you get
rid of it
then black will start to have a little
bit of problems with the safety of the
king
okay he brings his bishop back wow that
is
it doesn't trade pieces that is good but
it does mean that this bishop is
internally bad
and there's always going to be tricks
later on luxury move where the king
will have a hiding hole for oh
well we have a move and the move is a
little bit
unexpected because i fully expected this
waiting game to continue
until one side cracked we do have a move
from roger computer doesn't like it
yeah i'm surprised he's pushed his pawn
so early and also i'm surprised he's
pushed his pawn two squares
i expected that pawn to step forward one
square to undermine white's central pawn
but with this pawn push pushing it two
squares
i don't really see what black's threat
is there's no immediate idea
you're not opening up the center which
you need to do at some point for black
yeah very strange by timor raj above the
analysis board actually just to show
what might happen right now
okay he follows my idea he just pushes
this pawn forward one square
ivanka i think you wanted to capture
this pawn on passant because
it has just moved twice on its first go
and we do know that
if you have a pawn on your fifth rank if
your opponent moves two pawns to buy up
try and bypass
it you can actually capture as if it
just moved once and this would have been
fine as well maybe black white could
push forward on the left
but mag does he switch the play to the
other side look at how look at this pawn
structure kaia
um current position sorry um if we catch
up with the game
then now black has pushed his pawn
forward on the left
this is completely blocked i mean i'm
trying to find an
analogy for this one but this is
completely blocked on this side the
center also completely blocked
and plays all going to be about this
right side of the board now who can
maneuver better on this side
black retreating his knight the queen
stepping forward it's just
completely blocked right now all pieces
still on the board black's starting to
switch his pieces
know how he's switched his pieces
towards the right side now
later on white tonight stepping back
later on black will move this
night he's training the bishops first
he's gonna move
this night later um for example if the
rook moves and
later on he needs a lot of preparation
but he's gonna try and break
with this one eventually i expect to see
20 moves of maneuvering first
yeah and the maneuvering has begun
because uh magnus has just played one of
those
mysterious rook moves where he's moved
his rook
to in front of a pawn it looks like that
rook is not going to do anything so he's
getting
ready for that battle that opening in
the center and so he's getting ready to
push this
pawn two squares forward and just to
release
the rook and before he would do that i
agree david i think we're going to see a
lot more maneuvering um
okay we're going to see the trade of
bishops
and uh the king tucks itself away in the
corner
i would be tempted to carry on building
i wouldn't be tempted to do something
immediate now i would be
move my rook towards the center get
ready for this
look at magnus's expression though he's
surprised by that last move he was maybe
tempted to push forward okay he does
retreat his queen that queen retreat was
about to happen anyway
black was about to just retreat his
knight next to the black king and kick
that queen away
so magnus preempts that attack on his
queen
steps her back magnus he's getting ready
to maybe throw his
f pawn up the board so to create some
tension in the center maybe finally
open up some lines i should say though
23 moves the last turn we did see that
trader bishop
finally some pieces have cleared off
they have been hoovered off the board
yeah i was going to say we we have to
see
some intelligent thinking from rajabov
because he has to prepare for that
uh pawn break so white goes for it
immediately i was about to say this is
the move we're looking for from magnus
if not now then at least very soon and
he goes for it immediately he doesn't
hang around
the pawns do get traded off black about
to install a night in the middle
every single piece on the board and so
the rook
okay he's not taking my advice i was
like pick up that rook that's not
working and
move it and move it on the open line but
instead we'll use that idea shortly
yes if it's possible there might be some
drawbacks but he has to try and support
that knight in the middle of the board
we might see a trade of knights but
black would just replace his strong
knight
with the other one and now maybe it's
time
like you say to bring white's rook in
the corner into the action first okay
i was about to say first maybe white
could centralize his knight but no
he does bring his rook into the fray
and okay train of knights black's gonna
install a second knight into the middle
of the board
if possible now you have a choice
actually i was going to say how i was
going to retreat
my rook in order to liberate the
diagonal for the queen
to start looking at the black king then
maybe the black queen will join the
action so i think you need to bring your
rook up the board
to block off that black queen black's
bishop
stuck on his home square while timor
rajabov
in this must win situation brings his
bishop out sacrificing his bishop
but he has severed the connection
between the two white rooks
white's rooks no longer connected that
bishop move
it's either very good or it's very bad
but magnus he is calling rajabos bluff
he sacrifices his rook
for that bishop now with pawn takes pawn
what black's queen attacked by white's
remaining rook
that black queen's gonna have to move
away and magnus despite the fact he only
needs to draw
he's sacrificing he's going on the
attack now and
it does look very good for white so i
must say black's queen i think the main
issue is black's queen doesn't have a
safe square
yeah no matter where the black queen
goes she's going to be in trouble okay
she goes to the edge of the board
attacking
white's knight it's most natural the
more the bar thinks the
the higher it goes saying eight
advantage for magnus carlsen what's
happening here
yeah the white knight did jump in
knights on f5 they will thrive
and that white knight is beautiful
white's pawn as well stepping up
checking the black king the blacking's
actually trapped you just need one
killer blow
to actually uh check it later on to
checkmate it
why tonight meanwhile just snacking on
pawns just
everything is falling apart so that
black rook was attacked it attacked the
white knight the knight stepping back to
its dreams square
there were other squares as well it
could have used maybe but white's knight
protecting that white pawn that intruder
in black's position
next to the black king white actually
has two pawns now as well
for that exchange sacrifice that we
mentioned earlier for that material
white's pawn stepping forward clearing a
square for the white queen to check that
black king along
a light square diagonal it's it's deadly
black king
is doomed i'm just really impressed by
magnus's play and
rajabov does make the move that i
suggested but very very little
is it basically over is magnus with a
one and a half foot in the final right
now
i think yeah almost there he just needs
to control his emotions not get too
excited
and uh he's nearly there and
uh magnus is so ruthless when it comes
to these type of positions
and he has this ability ability as
almost super human just to keep himself
calm
yeah so white's queen did give check
black's rook had to block now the bishop
steps back
attacking the black queen is that queen
trapped it's almost trapped right now
actually maybe it is trapped the black
queen about to drop off the board as
well
how to attack without sacrificing pieces
um
well worth a check out and uh
resigns the black queen about to be
trapped
it's over magnus carlsen is the winner
of the semifinal against raj above he is
ready
for the big final in the